[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه معي العيال اختيار استهلوها بابرز
العناوين
المعارك تحت تجمعوا على اطراف
مستودعات اسلحه اوكرانيه في دنياك
يا لهوي
تجدد الهدى في ايران والنظام يواجه
المحتاجين في طهران بالرصاص الحي
لاول مره منذ ثلاث سنوات التحالف يعود الى
الرقه ومصادر تكشف عن نيته بناء قاعده
عسكريه هناك
تشارلز ويكشف سر كراهيته
[موسيقى]
بعد ساعات من وقف الهدنه المعلنه من طرف
واحد من قبل موسكو في اوكرانيا اشتدت
المعارك على محاور كل من باخ موت ودنياسك
شرقي البلاد واستانفات القوات الروسيه
قصفها على كافه القواعد العسكريه
الاوكرانيه في كل المحاور والمدن التابعه
لمقطعه دنياسكو لوجاس معلنه تدمير
مستودعات اسلحه اوكرانيه هناك هذا وكان
الجيش الاوكراني قد اعلن ان قوته الجويه
والصاروخيه استهدفت سته وعشرين موقعا
روسيا خلال 24 ساعه فيما قالت سلطات دنيا
اسكلا انفصاليه ان القوات الاوكرانيه
استخدمت صاروخ توشكا اوه في ضرباته وفي
ضربات اليوم هذا وتحتزم المعارك في محور
باخم بعد ما سيطرت قواته الروسيه على
مواقع في شماليه المدينه وشرقها وجنبها
مطوقه بلده سوليدار ومدينه
طبعا في خطوه انتقاميه وصفات وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه تنفيذ الضربه لمقتل جنود روس في
ضربه صاروخيه في مكه ليله راس السنه وقالت
الدفاع الروسيه انها قصفت مبنى فكرهماتوس
شرقي اوكرانيا ما اودى بحياه اكثر من 600
جندي اوكرانيه بدورها نفات كيا بالخبر
ومقتل هذا العدد معتبره البيان الروسي
دعايه مبال
[موسيقى]
ردينكا نفذت القوات الروسيه عمليه
انتقاميه خلال 24 ساعه الماضيه اكتشفت
المخابرات الروسيه نقاط الانتشار المؤقته
للقوات الاوكرانيه في كرامات
الجنود قتل منهم اكثر من 600 جندي في هجوم
صاروخين روسي
ديناص قراءه الاخبار
تم في هذه العمليه من الاساس
ما وصفته هي عمليه انتقاميه قامت بها
موسكو ردت فعل على ما جرى ليله راس السنه
بسقوط 10
في ضرباتهم اوكرانيه طبعا لو فيك الحقيقه
بان الهدنه كانت شيء غريب وشيء طبعا لما
يعني لم يصل الى ما رغبه موسكو وطبعا
رفضها كثيرون في الداخل الروسي باعتبارها
لم ت- يعني لم تصل الى نتائج باعتبر قامت
بيردد فعل عسكريه على اماكن على الاماكن
التي خرجت منها ضربات اوكرانيه وسقط في
خلال ساعات الهدنه اكثر من 100 و20 جندي
اوكراني لكن طبعا ما حدث اليوم هو يعني
عنوان كل الحوارات ان كانت في الاخبار وان
كانت في مواقع التواصل اجتماعي بان الضرب
بان موسكو عادت لضرباتها القويه وضربتها
الصاروخيه على النقاط التحتيه همم
العسكريا الجانب الاوكراني والاعداد طبعا
ونلاحظ ان بيان وزاره الدفاع اليوم ليتحدث
لاول مره منذ فتره طويله عن اسقاط اربعه
يعني طائرات حربيه اربع مقاتلات من طراسه
من غيره يعني ومن غيره لذلك طبعا هذا
البيان اليوم يعني في من اوله لاخره هو
محور الحديث اماكن عده تم ضربها لدى
الجانب الاخراني صفرات الانذار يعني منذ
سبع دقائق عقبه نهايه الهدنه التي انتهت
ليله الامس عند منتصف الليله بدات ضربات
الروسيه وانتشرت الاخبار كالنار في الهشيم
حول طبعا خارقه لا حول همم زباروجي
المدينه الرئيسيه التي تقع تحت يعني
للحديث نعم عبد الجواد للحديث عن الميدان
عن المعارك همم سننتقل الى الزميره
الاخبار رائد كيف هو سير المعارك هنا
خصوصا اننا نتحدث ان محور دونياسك اليوم
والاساس والطاقي على كل الاخبار الصوره
معك تفضل
الانفجارات واصوات القصف العنيف من
المدفعيه ومن راجمات الصواريخ على طوال
اليوم بالفعل هناك احداث كثيره شامله هذا
اليوم والمبدا من استهداف الجيش الاخراني
لمحطات الطاقه
اعترضت صواريخ الدفاعات الجويه همم
الروسيه اعترضت صاروخ توشكا او ايضا
بالفعل اصفر او قصف الاوكراني عن قتيلين
واصابات وما زال منهم تحت الانقاذ حتى
الان بينما نفذ كما اسلفت في ال اااه
الروسيه المقاتلات الروسيه كما اعلن
الدفاع الروسي وان المقاتلات الروسيه على
اهم الاستعداد همم
نقاط المعارك في العمليه العسكريه في
اوكرانيا بشكل استراتيجي وكانت النتيجه
القصبه المقاتلات الاوكرانيه بصواريخ موقع
عين
اوكرانيين كان يتركز بهذا بهذان الموقعان
همم اوكرانيه اعداد كبيره احدهما كان فيه
600 مقاتل والثالثه 400 مقاتل اسفلت هذه
العمليه حسب وزاره الدفاع الروسيه عن 600
كما ان هناك من ما زالوا تحت الانفاق حتى
الان همم غير همم يعني الاصابات المحور
الاهم هو المحور ضخم وسدار ماذا تفعل
قواتنا هناك بالفعل وهو خاصه من القوات
الشيشانيه اضافه الى الجنود الذين
في محاوله لاكمال الطوق على مدينه همم
السيطره على المدينه المداخله والبلده
المتاخمه وهي سردار في الناحيه الشماليه
بالفعل تمت امس سيطر على همم نقطه هامه
وهي نقطه نقطه
الشماليه همم والمعارك العليفه قتال شوارع
في الادار من اجل السيطره الكامله على
بلده سيلدار
وايه من تطويف الكامل
والتقدم نحو باخد الدفاع الاوكرانيه نفسها
تقول بان الاوضاع صعبه على الجنود هناك
الجنود الاوكرانيه
والجيش الروسي يؤكد انه خلال فتره ان لم
تكن قريبه فانه حتما سين ايه او سيحسن
معركه للسيطره على المدينه هي التي ستفتح
الى المدن الكبرى كرامه
بالفعل المعارك المحترمه في الشرق
الاوكراني بشكل عام وهمم يعني بنيت هي
المحور الاساسي شكرا لكم مراسله العربيه
عبر جواد رشد من موسكو ورعد الاخضر طبعا
من دنياك شكرا لكم على هذه الرسائل
للحرب بين روسيا واوكرانيا
بين المكاسب والخسائر احيانا هبوطا وصعودا
يسر كل طرف حتى اللحظه على استمرار الحرب
فرضيه الثانيه وهي اعلان وقف ليطلاق النار
من جانب روسيا مع الاكتفاء بما تحقق من
مكاسب فالرئيس الروسي حقق بالفعل جزءا قل
او كثر مما كان يسعى اليه
كم الخسائر البشريه والماديه ترهق الطرفين
في ما استنفذ جيشاه البلدين قدراتهما في
ظل معاناه من نقص في القوه البشريه
والعسكريه نقص لم يعد يبرروا خوض المزيد
من القتال
تخالف اوكرانيا التوقعات تنتصر في الحرب
وتجبر القوات الروسيه على الانسحاب الى
المواقع التي كانت عليها سابقا
روسيات تحقق انتصارا محتملا تحكم قبضتها
على كل الاراضي الاوكرانيه بما في ذلك
العاصمه كياب
بين سيناريوهات المحتمله وما هو على الارض
ليتضح ان فصول هذه الحرب لم تكتمل بعد
عصام عبد السلام العربيه
القنبله المثاليه سباق تسلح جديد بين
اوكرانيا وروسيا باستخدام الطائرات من دون
طيار في التفاصيل القنبله المثاليه سلاح
شديد يصنعه الجنود الاكرانيين يدويا
لاسقاطها من الطائرات من دون طيار لتدمير
الدبابات الروسيه وفق طبعا تقرير صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه ولكن كيف يتم
تصنيع هذه القنبله تعمل فرق من الجنود
الاوكرانيين في ورشه عمل صغيره في الشرقيه
اوكرانيا على صنع قنبله يدويه وزنها خفيف
جدا ويمكن اسقاطها من طائره من دون طيار
وتدمير دبابه روسيه تزن نحو 40 طنطا
القنبله المثاليه يجب ان تزن نحو صفر فاصل
49 كيلوغرام وهو اقصى وزن يمكن ان تحمله
الطائره من دون طيار من طراز كاماكس 3 شرح
جندي هنا اوكراني مسؤول عن فريق الطائرات
من دون طيار
الامريكيه هذه التفاصيل تتضمن طبعا المهمه
تعتبر صعبه جدا ودقيقه تجربه قنابل يدويه
ذات تصميمات مختلفه والعمل حول اليات
التفجير لضبطها وهو العمل وهذا ايضا العمل
هو جزء من سباق تسلح اوكراني اوسع
للطائرات من دون طيار مع روسيا كما ايضا
تابعنا التجارب على القنبله المثاليه
اثبتت حتى الساعه نجاحها بعد استخدامها
على الطائره من دون طيار او ما يعرف
بمافيك 3 الصينيه الصنع بسبب صغر حجمها
وعمر بطاريتها المناسبه في المقابل
المشاهدين يحاول الجيش الروسي ايضا مثل
الجيش الاكراني جعل الياته الصغيره غير
الماهوله اكثر فتكا حيث تستخدم روسيا
طائرات من دون طياره العسكريه الروسيه
الاكبر حجما مثل طائرات شاهد 100 و36
ذاتيه التفجير والتي تصنع اراد وتطلق بشكل
متكرر لتدمير البنيه التحتيه الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]
اكدت وزاره الدفاع في بيلاروسيا ان موسكو
ويمسك كثافه تدريبات العسكريه المشتركه
بناءا على ما اكتسبته روسيا من خبره في
القتال في اوكرانيا مع التركيز على ما
وصفوه بحب المدن وقال وزاره الدفاع انها
عززت تعاونها مع نظيرتها الروسيه حيث
تخططان لاجراء تدريبات جويه مشتركه واشارت
الى ان التدريبات على حرب المدن تحظى
باهتمام خاص في هذه المباراه وياتي
التعاون العسكري المكثفه بين البلدين
الحنيفين وسطك هناك في اوكرانيا والغرب
بانام موسكو قد تستغلوا من سته منصه
الانطلاقه وشن هجوم جديد على اوكرانيا من
الجهه الشماليه
[موسيقى]
في ايران مخاوف كبيره اثارها تعيين القائد
الجديد للشرطه الايرانيه
وتجسدات في زياده مستوى العنف والارهاب
بحق الاحتجاجات والمحتاجين في البلاد وهو
ما حصل بالفعل حين واجهت الشرطه الايرانيه
المحتاجين في العاصمه طهران بالرصاص الحيض
قبل قليل النظام الايراني لم يتوقف هنا
على امل قمع الاحتجاجات بل لجا الى تغيير
قاده المحافظات غير الفارسيه واستبدالهم
بجنيرالات تابعين للحراسات التغييرات
مشاهدينا ماستت ابرز المحافظات الكرديه
كمحافظه كرمنشاه ومحافظات عربيه مثل
الاحواز
سالوهم خدمه شلونك عزيز
صدور حكم قضائي بالسجن خمس سنوات بحق
فائزه هاشمي رفسه جاني عقب مثولها امام
محكمه للنظر بالتهم الموجهه اليها وكانت
نفسا جاني قد حكمت سابقا بالحبس سته اشهر
ومنعها خمس سنوات من الانشطه السياسيه
وثقافيه والصافيه
عضو في حزب كوادر البناء الاصلاحيه
الايراني
دعونا مشاهدينا نذكر بالمقطع الذي تسبب
باعتقال
رفستنجاني ثم الحكم عليها بالسجن في اغسطس
الماضي حيث انتقدت فيه بقوه نظام الايراني
واتهمت القاده بالضعف محاولات حل الازمات
والاصلاح
كل ما يحدث في الداخل والخارج كل هذا بسبب
ضعف حكومتنا وليس لاي منهم اي حل لتعويض
عن الوضع الراهن او لا يبدو انهم قاده
فاعلون وقادرون على قياده الدوله نحو
الاصلاح وحل الازمات لذا فعلوا ما يظهروا
قوتهم للتعويض عن هذا الضعف العميق
وفي ايران ايضا وملف الاحواز او اعتدى حرس
او ملف مواز اعتدى حرس جامعه طهران بالضرب
على طلاب كليه الفنون الجميله ومنعوه من
اقامه مراسم الذكرى السنويه الثالثه
لضحايا اسقاط الطائره الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]
شايفين شايفين
لاحياء ذكرى اسقاط الطائره الاوكرانيه
المنكوبه بصاروخين اطلقهما الحرس الثوري
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ينضم الينا المشاهدين
البحث في الشان الايراني استاذ يعقوب يعني
منذ انحط الطائرات الخميني في مقبره الذهب
الزهراء وحتى يعني هذه الساعه كل ما تازم
وضع النظام يلجا الى السيناريو المعروف
وهو استخدام الحد الاقصى من القوه اليوم
هذا السيناريو الذي انعكس سلبا عليه كيف
سيقمل
طيبه لك قناه العربيه بكل تاكيد ولا يوجد
تراجع في قاموس هذا النظام وخاصه في قاموس
المرشد الاعلى لهذا النظام
جدا معقده تشبه بالحجره
تهوت مع جميع الاحجار لذلك لا يمكنهم
اجراء اصلاحات حقيقيه او تقديم تنازلات
للمحتجين او للاشخاص الذين قالوا بهذه
التنازلات وبالتالي الحديث عن الاصلاحات
التي اتى به قريبا وشخصيات مقربه من مرشد
كانوا دائما يقولون بان الاصلاحات يجب ان
تتم وفقا لافكار المرشد المؤسس الخميني
وافكار هذا المرشده وبالتالي نحن نبقى
نروح في مكاننا لانه هذه الدوله هي اساسا
قائمه على افكار المرشدين لهذه الدوله
اعتقد هذا النظام يعتقد بان المواجهه
المواجهه واستخدام العنف المفرد تجاه
المحتاجين هو الحل الوحيد امامه لانه
هؤلاء المحتاجين مطالبهم واضحه واسقاط
النظام
ولا اتوقع ذلك انهم ايضا لن يرضوا بهذه
الاصلاحات الشكليه التي تتعب فيها النظافه
منذ بدايه هذه التظاهرات واعتمد سيناريو
يعني من السيناريوهات التي اعتمدها هي
اعمادها القوه اليوم القوه ايضا هي عماد
التضاهرات من خلال صلابه الموقف ويعني
الاستمراريه التي ما زالت حتى هذه الساعه
بين صراحتين القوتين اين من سينكسر
بالنهايه
انا اتوقع بان يعني قمع المحتجين وحزنهم
هذا الناجم عن هذا القمع يتحول في كل لحظه
الى طاقه هائله للتخلص من هذا النظام
الدموي في كل لحظه هم يصلون الى وعي بان
هذا النظام يجب ان يسقط وبالتالي اسقاط
استخدام هذا العنف لم لم يعد يجدي الكثير
من النفع قد ينجح في بعض من الحالات او
لايام بخمد الاحتجاجات ولكنها نرى تخرج
بطريقه ثانيه تاخذ منحه مختلف مثل اليوم
الاحتجاجاته ليست تلك التي فقد تطهر
بالشارع هنالك اضرابات في مثلا بازار
طهران الكبير الذي ترى والعكس كبير عن
الاقتصاد الايراني هنالك الكثير من
المذيعين للاموال سحب واموالهم مما انعكس
على انهيار العمله الايرانيه فبالتالي
الكل يشارك بطريقه الخاصه في التعبير مع
هذه الاحتجاجات وخاصه يجب ان نعرف بانه في
ايران وفقا للاحصائيات الرسميه هناك اكثر
من 40 مليون شخص يعيشون تحت خط فقط و
هنالك 20 مليون شخص يعيشون بمشاكل
اقتصاديه فهذه اذا اذا تسمع الايرانيين
الموجودين خارج ايران يقولون بان
الايرانيين ليس لديهم شيء ليخفروه
وبالتالي من هنا يعني هذه القوه التي لا
يمكن كسره بالشارع ولا بالقوه ولا باي شيء
اريد ان اوصل اليه بانه وبالتالي هؤلاء
الناس ليس لديهم شيء
نحن امام 60 مليون شخص يعانون من مشاكل
اقتصاديه وامام شرائح واسعه من المجتمع من
الاطباء والسياسيين والقوميات كذلك في
ايران هي اساسا تعاني وممه بشكل كبير من
هذا النظام سواء على اساس الحقوق القوميه
مثل المعذره القوميه في ايران على همم
فيما يتعلق بالحريات الفرديه للكثير من
الشرائح المجتمع في المركز في مناطق ذلك
كل هذه الفئات هي اجتمعت الان بطريقه اخرى
تعبر عن تضمنها للمشاركه شكرا لك استاذ
يعقوب سعيد البحث عشان الايراني حدثنا من
امستردام
تتابعونا مشاهدينا ولكن بعد قليل
يعولوا على دعم كافه افراد الشعب للمحافظه
[موسيقى]
بينما تتسارع الخطوات التركيه نحو التقارب
بعد نظام الاسد تختل الولايات المتحده
خطوات الميدانيه مع قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه شمال شرقي سوريا مصادر كرديه
عسكريه كشفت للعربيه ان القوه الامريكيه
دفعت خلال الايام القليله الفائته بمزيد
من التعزيزات العسكريه واللوجيه الى مناطق
عده في الحسكه والتي تتركز فيها القواعد
الامريكيه التعزيزات وصلت الى قواعد
التحالف في ارميلان شرقي القامشلي وجنوب
الحسكه اضافه للقاعده العسكريه في تل بيدر
شمال الحسكه والتعزيزات بحسب المصادر
الكرديه طبعا كانت نحو 40 شاحنه محمله
بمواد عسكريه ومعدات لوجيسيه وشاحنات
مغلقه وصهاريج للوقود بالاضافه لعربات
عسكريه قتاليه
[موسيقى]
بعد تصعيد التركي الاخير ضد الاكراد في
سوريا ارسل التحالف الدولي مزيدا من الدعم
العسكري الى قواعده العسكريه بالحسكه
وكثافه عملياته المشتركه مع قسد
سات عوده التحالف الى مدينه الرقه بعد
انسحابه منها قبل ثلاث سنوات وكشفت مصادر
كرديه ايضا عنيه التحالف انشاء قاعده
عسكريه في مدينه الرقه تحديدا على الضفه
الشرقيه لنهر الفرات قبل ذلك كانت واشنطن
قد زودت المقاتلين الاكراد في سوريا ولاول
مره مشاهدينا بصواريخ مضاده للطائرات من
طراز تاو المحموله على الكتف
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا نواف خليل مدير
المركز الكردي للدراسات استاذ نواف يعني
اليوم هناك طبعا مصلحه روسيه تركيه سوريه
بما يحصل من تقارب بالملف السوري اليوم
ايضا هناك مصالح امريكيه موجوده منذ زمن
مصلحه الاكراد هل يمكن التضحيه بها مجددا
وهل تعولون على موقف يعني جدي امريكي
بالوقوف الى جانب الاكراد
مساء الخير لكي والمشاهديه العربيه اينما
كانوا اييه بالدرجه الاساسيه القرد وحلفاء
وحلفاء يعودون على قدراتهم الذاتيهم على
الحاضن الاجتماعيات لكن ككل الدول وكل
الكائنات التي لا تملك الكثير يعني هناك
قراءه اعتقد كانت دقيقه مكنت هؤلاء من ان
يلتقوا مع التحالف الدولي في ايدول 2014
وهذا التحالف مستمر في محاربه الارهاب
والان اعتقد المتغيرات ايضا تفرض على
الولايات المتحده مزيد من الدعم سيوان في
مواجهه
ما تقوم به داعش وايضا نتيجه الوضع
والتموضع الروسي ده في السعوديه والايراني
وخاصه بعد ما قال قال الرئيس الامريكي
جوبيد من ان الاتفاق النووي شبه ميت كل
ذلك
ينعكس على الداخل السوري الذي تحول الى
همم يعني هناك الاطراف الداخليه والاق
ليم وكلهم بالتاكيد يتحرك وفق مصلحته هنا
يعني القدوه حلفاء
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه اعتقد يعني تمكنوا
من الوصول الى مشترك نقاط مشتركه وتقاطع
مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والدول
الغربيه التي لها مصلحه في استمرار محاربه
داعش وايضا ربما في مزيد منع المزيد من
التمدد الايراني بالروسي داخل سوريا
بالاضافه الى مواجهه اي همم غزوه واحتلال
تركيا
معطيات عن التعزيز الامريكي في شمالي
سوريا باي مناطق همم كيف يمكن اني ينعكس
في حال يعني الذهاب الى مسار جديد بهذا
الصراع
اللافت ان التعزات الامريكيه الجديده جاءت
بعد اعاده تاهيل مقر الفرقه السابعه عشره
التي كانت تتواجد فيها القوات السعوديه
وبعد ذلك استودعت عليها مختلف الجماعات
سواء 11 ومن المجموعات الاخرى وفي في
منطقه الرقه وانسحبت من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بعد الخطا
العتيجي الكبير الذي ارتكبه الرئيس
الامريكي دونالد ترامب والنجم عن ذلك
احتلال منطقه
سيرك انير استعينج الابيض الان هناك بعد
ثلاثه سنوات العوده الى تلك المنطقه وبناء
قاعده في مقر الفرقه السابعه عشر وقاعده
اخرى داخل مدينه الرقه لتعزيز التواجد
الامريكي ولي ايه مزيد من التاكيد على
محاربه داعش ومعرفه الاخطار التي همم يمكن
ان تتسبب بها هذه المجموعه اخطر على
المستوى العالمي يعني هناك اكثر من 10
الاف داعش في السجون وهناك عشرتنا الاف من
الدواعش في المخيمات
والتاكيدات الامريكيه خاصه بعد التهديدات
تركيا زادت التاكيدات وازداد الحضور
الامريكي
واليوم دخلت في الامريكيه الثانيه همم
محمله بالاسلحه والعتاب وحتى همم
واشنطن همم يعني منظومه صواريخ محموله على
الكتف كنا قد ذكرناها بالتقرير قبل قليل
هل يعني هي تاتي اليوم بوجهها الاسلحه
الاخرى الموجوده هناك التركيه والروس
خصوصا ان هناك مصلحه يعني لاضعاف الجانب
الكردي من قبل هذين الطرفين
يعني تتناقض مصالح هذه الاطراف في محاربه
حلفاء
بالنسبه لصواريخ التو انا لا استطيع ان
انفي او اكد لكن ما استطيع تاكيده ان كل
التسليح الامريكيات في اطار محاربه داعش
وايضا الاخطار الناجمه من الاطراف همم
مثلا سيدنا في الاول الاخيره اكثر من مره
محاوله الهجوم على حقل كونغو
واغلب الظن او المعلومات تؤكد ان الطرف
الذي يحاول الهجوم على حقل كوليكو الذي
تتواجد فيه قوات التحالف يعني قوات
الامريكيه وقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه من
الجانب الايراني يعني الاسلحه والعتاب
الذي ياتي في اطار حمايه القوات الامريكيه
استمرار الحرب وايضا حمايه الشركاء
الولايات المتحده
مجمل الوضع يؤكد ان الولايات المتحده تعيد
التنوضع وبقوه بعد ثلاثه اسحبه من تلك
المناطق في مواجهه عده اطراف
والاستمرار الحرب ايضا على الداعش فيما
يتعلق بالقرب جون كيربي قالها بوضوح لن
يكون الطرف الكردي والخاسر انما الان
نتحدث عن يعني اذا حدث التوافق الذي
يتحدثون عنه سيكون همم اطراف من المعارضه
التي سلمت كل شيء النظام في تركيا هم
الخاسر الاكبر وسيكون كل شيء بالسوري
والخاصه نحن هنا نتحدث عن يعني الملايين
السوريين الذين همم هجروا ونزحوا
هناك مئات الى اهداف الذين ستكون
المختفين وليس الطرف الكردي الذي يركز
عليه الافلام اهلا وسهلا هذا السؤال
الاساسي اليوم هل تتخلى واشنطن عن
المعارضه وعن الاكراد في ان المعن امم
يعني شكرا لك استاذ نواف خليل على كل
الشرح الذي قدمته مدير المركز الكردي
للدراسات
في سوريا ايضا انعش مرسوم العفو الاخير
الذي اصدره رئيس النظام بشار الاسد اواخر
ديسمبر الماضي انا 10 عمل السماسره الذين
يستغلون الاهالي المعتقلين ماليا من خلال
اهامهم بقدرتهم على الافراج عنهم او الكشف
عن مصيرهم وحذرت رابطه معتقلي ومفقوديه
سجن سجن صيدنايا الاهالي من الوقوع بيد
شبكه احتلال شديده همم مبديه او مبينه ان
الشبكه تتواصل مع اهالي المعتقلين وتزودهم
بمعلومات عن ابنائهم ويعرضون عليهم
المساعده لاخلاء سبيلهم واضافات الرابطه
ان شبكه الاحتلال تزود عائلات المعتقلين
بمستندات رسميه صحيحه من حيث الشكل لكنها
مزوره في مضمون مرشحه ان يكون من بين
اعضاء الشبكه رجال الامن وموظفون حكومه
قبل ذلك
دخلت الى محافظه ادلب في شمالي غرب سوريا
اليوم قافله مساعدات انسانيه قبل يومين من
موعد تجديد مجلس الامن العام باليه ادخال
المساعدات الى المناطق التي لا تسيطر
عليها قوه النظام السوري وعبرت القافله
خطوط التماس من مناطق سيطره النظام الى
مناطق تسيطر عليها فصائل مسلحه في ادلب
وهي تضم 18 شاحنه محمله بمساعده الانسانيه
مقدمه من برنامج الاغذيه العالميه التابعه
للامم المتحده
[موسيقى]
قال محمد المنفي رئيس المجلس الرئاسي للبي
ان مفتاح الحل للازمه الليبيه ليس في
المحافظه للنفوذ والسلطه وليس في تقاسم
الموارد والمال ولكنه في رقب الصدع والعفو
والمصالحه والسعاده روح الوطنيه الاخويه
والعيش المشترك والممارسه الديمقراطيه في
تسويه الصراع مشيرا الى ان كل الصياغه
المجربه في ليبيا لبناء السلطه بقت بالفشل
لانها تجاهلت الحل واحرقت المراحل
ان مفتاح الحل لازمه هذا الوطن وهو ليس في
المحافظه
السلطه والنفوس وليس في تقاسم الموارد
والمال ولكنه في رعب الصدا وجبر الضرر
والعفو والمصالحه انه في استعاده روح
الوحده الوطنيه الاخويه والعيش المشترك في
هذا الوطن المعطاه انه في رجوء الرجوع الى
حكمه الاجداد والاباء المؤسسين والاحتكام
الى قواعد العرف والدين والممارسات
السلميه والديمقراطيه في تسويه الصراع
ايها الساده ان كل الصيغ المجربه في ليبيا
لبناء السلطه بقت بالفشل لانها تجاهلت
الحل واحرقت المراحل
وقفزت على مطالب الشعب الليبي الى مطالب
الساسه
ان المجلس الرئاسي الليبي لم يكن يوما
جزءا من هذه المشكله فقد وقف متماسكا على
مسافه متساويه من جميع الاطراف اطراف
الصراعي على السلطه التي لم يكن هو يوما
من المتمسكين بها او المتنافسين عليها وقد
التزم المجلس الرئاسي
بمهنته الساميه في خلق الارضيه السياسيه
والقانونيه
والاجتماعيه للمصالحه وقد بذلنا وما زلنا
نبذل في سبيل هذا الهدف كل جهد ووقت في
ظروف كنا كلنا نعلم من البدايه انها لن
تكون مواتيه وان الانجاز المحرز لم يصل
بعد الى مرحله جني الثمار لمشروع المصالحه
الوطنيه
في لبنان طلب رئيس مجلس النواب نبيه بري
بابقاء جلسه انتخاب الرئيس الجديد المقبله
مفتوحه حتى انتخاب رئيس الجمهوريه بدلا من
ما وصفها بالجلسات الفلكلوريه المعروفه
مسبقا مصيرها فيما طلب سمير جعجع رئيس حزب
القوات اللبنانيه بان لا يغادر احد
البرلمان حتى انتخاب الرئيس وقال جعجع ان
المطلوب من رئيس مجلس النواب لدى عودته
الحادي عشر لانتخاب رئيس الجمهوريه ان
يبلغ جميع الكتل النيابيه سلفا بانه لن
يقفل الجلسه
مشاهدينا التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
الصين تعلق حسابات وسائل التواصل المنتقده
لسياسات كورونا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
لا تاكلوا كثيرا وتصنع ملابسها بنفسها
ووالدي يغار منها تصريحاته للامير هاري
تحمل نزورا انتقادات جديده للعائله الملكه
فبعد ايام من طرح مذكرات الامير للبيع قبل
الموعد الرسمي لنشرها وما تضمنته من مزاعم
جديده عن الخلاف
والشقاق داخل العائله الملكيه البريطانيه
كتابه الذي طرح للبيع في اسبانيا قبل خمسه
ايام من موعد اصداره الرسمي احتل المرتبه
الاولى على قائمه الكتب الاكثر مبيعا على
موقع امازون في بريطانيا رغم ان استطلاعات
الراي اشعارات الى ان الكثير من
البريطانيين ضاقوا زرعنا بميلادراما
العائله المالكه برمتها وان الكشف عن مزيد
من المفاجاه لن يغير اراء هؤلاء سواء
المتعاطفه مع هاري وزوجته مجد ماركل او
تلك المنتقده
ولكن بالنسبه ليها رئه الالتزام بالصمت لن
يجعل الامور افضل وفق ما اعلنه في
مقابلاته مع اي تي في البريطانيه
[موسيقى]
واوفقا لذوق وهو الامير هاري فان والده
الملك تشارلز اخبره بان زوجته
في اليوم الذي ماتت فيه الملكه اليزابيث
كما انه رفض سابقا انتقال مع كل العيش
معهم وفقا لمذكرات الامير طبعا والذي قال
اي الامير هاري انه يفكر بسخريه
لانها بان تكلفه ماركل لتوفير الطعام
والماوى كانت ضئيل بالنظر الى انها لا
تتمتع بشهيه كبيره ويمكنها صنع ملابسها
الخاصه كتاب ادخل العائله الملكيه في اكبر
ازماتها منذ مسلسل عرض في التسعينيات
وتناول انهيار زواج من الاميره الراحله
ديانا والدته ويلي الكتاب لم تعلق عليه
حتى الساعه العائله الملكيه والذي جاء بعد
اربعه اشهر فقط من وفاه الملكه اليزابيث
وتوليد تشار للعرش
ولا احد يعرف اين كانوا او ما كانوا
يفعلونه ليله وفاه والدتي بكيت مره واحده
اثناء مراسم الدفن ولا حاجه لخوض في مدى
غرابه الامر او الذنب الذي شعرت به انا
وليام ايضا الجميع كانوا يعتقدون ويشعرون
بانهم يعرفون امي واقربوا شخصين منها
واكثر شخصين احبتهما لم يتمكنا من التعبير
عن اي مشاعره في تلك اللحظه
[موسيقى]
ببساطه هم يرغبون في ان يظهر بصوره
المتمردين اليس كذلك يبتعدون عن انفسهم
ويحاولون الابتعاد ايضا عن العائله
الملكيه
اعتقد ان الناس يشعرون بفضول حول النظام
الملكي وقصصه نريد ان نعرف ما حدث بالفعل
وما هي الاحداث التي حصلت
اعتقد ان هناك الكثير من الاشياء التي كان
من الممكن ان يتعمق فيها هاري لكنني اعتقد
انه كان يحترم عائلته وامتنع عن فعل ذلك
وفي افغانستان تتوالى ردود الافعال على
تعليقات الامير هاري العربيه تلتقي
بمسؤولين في طلبان الذين يصفون الامير
بقاتل الافغان الابرياء
الا هذه التعليقات وهي غير من فيض يقول
عبد الحق حماد مسؤول بارز في وزاره
الثقافه والاعلام الافغانيه مطالبا
بتحقيقات شامله في جميع الجرائم الحربيه
التي ارتكبتها القوات الاجنبيه في
افغانستان خلال العشرين سنه الماضيه
البريطانيه
بلال كريمي هو الثاني الذي يصف تعليقات
الامير هاري بالهجينه والمسيئه للمملكه
المتحده وخاصه لاسره الامير مضيفا ان
الامير هاري قتل الابرياء من الافغان
جميع القنوات الاجنبيه قامت بمثل هذه
الجرائم الحربيه
صوره صغيره لضرر الشديد الذي الحقته
القوات الغربيه بشعب افغانستان خلال
مهمتهم القتاليه هناك هي تعبر عن تلك
الصوره البشعه التي عاشها الشعب الافغاني
وبالفعل هؤلاء قدير ارتكبوا اكبر مخالفات
قانونيه بسطح افغانستان وكذلك على مستوى
العالم الطرف الاول يعترف بالجريمه
ثاني يعتبرها وحشيه ضد الانسانيه مطالبا
زملاء الامير هاري بالاعتراف بجرائمهم
التي ارتكبوها خلال مهامهم القتاليه في
افغانستان عبد الاله نادر العربيه كابول
عادل درويش المعتمد في مجلس العموم
البريطاني استاذه عادل اختيار هذه للمصار
الصدامي التدبير يعني الذي ممكن ان يقطع
العلاقه نهائيا مع العائله لماذا ذهب نحو
هذا النوع من العلاقه مع العائله الملكيه
والانتقاد العلني غير المسبوق للعائله
هو طبعا يعني انا اشعر بالاسئله حاله حاله
هو شاب واضح انه الطالب نفسيا
لان اولا هو قطع جسوره طبعا
في قلبه حيسامحه في يوم من الايام
هو خطا على الجسور ومع اهم قاعده بتاعته
وهي الجيش زملائه اذا كان الجيش لان
الانتقادات كبيره جدا من الجيش
النظامي
هو كان يعيش داخل العائله الملكه وكان
يعتبر يعني فرد من العائله اليوم حينما
خرج ومن المعروف انه يعني صدمه والدته
ربما لم يتخطاها اليوم اعتباره بانه مضطرب
عقليا هل هي رده فعل طبيعيه من قبل
العائله حفاظا على صورتها
ما ليش اي حاجه انا اللي باقول انا اللي
باقول
اكثر من مقابل الرولد
[موسيقى]
عن موضوع افغانستان تحديدا وعما تتحدث عنه
وطبعا يتنافى مع يعني العقيده العسكريه مع
مع المنطق همم يعني سليم بهذا الموضوع اذا
ما كانت تعلم العائله بوجود بعض المشاكل
النفسيه عند الامير هاري لماذا تم ارساله
الى مكان يولد اصلا مشاكل نفسيه
كل افراد الاسره
المعلوم
الاشخاص الصحيحين ممكن ان يخرجوا هناك بظل
الظروف الصعبه بمشاكل النفسيه اذا ما
كانوا يعلمون بانه وضعه نفس الدقيق لماذا
تم ارساله الى هذه المنطقه بالذات
من بعد بعد التعليقات الكتبت هل سيجرى
التحقيق في هذا الشان ام لا طبعا المساله
هنا تقدير الاطباء السيكلودين في الجيش
يعني في هذا الوقت كان هاري بيتصرف بشكل
طبيعي بالعكس هو كان محبوب جدا ولما رجع
من افغانستان
فيبدو ان في حاجه حصلت من الزواج
ممثله امريكيه وحبها
اخبار سيئه ههه بريطانيا
الغربيه لكل يعني المختصين بهذا الموضوع
يعني الهجوم على ملك بريطانيا المستقبل
لماذا وتصوير بكانه خان الامانه وخان ثقته
تحديدا واعتدى عليه هل هي هل هو مبرر
ده اللي هو الشعبياته كثيرا واعتقد ان ان
الناس هتتعاطف اكثر معها
سمو الامير وليام لماذا لان دي عامله زي
حرب العصابات من الجماعات الارهابيه بتفكر
قنبله وعارفه ان الطرف الاخر مش هيرد
عليها
هو امامهم التلفزيونات والمنصات
التعبير في الصحافه باشكالها المتنوعه
والاسر الملكه والقصر لا يرد على هذه
الامور لا تقليد قديم جدا ان لا يخرج عن
القصر اي ردود او اي افعال واا الموضوع
هيتنسي لكن هو عاوز الكتاب بتاعه ويضيعه
وده عاطف كبير جدا هنا مع الناس ومع
معلقين اللي زيه مع الصحفيين ومع الناس
اللي بتكتب
شكرا لك يا استاذ عادل درويش همم المراسل
المعتمه في مجلس العموم البريطاني على
وجودك معنا
[موسيقى]
اشار رئيس الوزراء السويديه لان بلاده
واثقه من ان تركيا ستوافق على طلبها
للانضمام الى حلف شمال الاطلسيه الناتو
مؤكده في ذات الصدد ان السويد لا يمكنها
تلبيه جميع مطالب تركيا للحصول على دعم
عضويه الناتو واصفا هذه المطالب بالمبالغ
فيها هذا ووقعت سويد وفنلندا وتركيا
اتفاقيه الثلاثيه عام 2022 تهدف الى
التغلب على اعتراضات تركيا على عضويه
البلدين
وتمهد الطريق الانضمام البلدين الواقعين
في شمالي اوروبا الى حيث
تركيا تركيا
لكنها تقول ايضا انها تريد امورا لا
نستطيع ولا نريد تلبيتها نحن على قناعه
بان التركيه ستتخذ قرارا ولا نعرف متى
تحديدا
[موسيقى]
تدا
عيه رفضت قوات حفظ السلام التي يقودها
الناتو في كوسوفي رفضت عوده القوات
الصربيه
الماضي عندما تصاعدت التوترات في كوسوفو
بسبب اعتقال شرطيين السابقين من اصل سردي
ماده الى اغلاق طرق شماليه البلاد وتصر
صربيا على ان مئات من قواتها الامنيه لهم
الحق في اعاده الانتشار بموجب قرار الامم
المتحده الذي اعقب الحرب وقالت ان عوده
قواتها الى كوسوفو ستساعد في خفض التوتر
وهو ادعاء رفضته كسوفه والمسؤولين او
المسؤولون الغربيون بشده ومن المقرر ان
يزور وفد امريكي كبيره المنطقه الاسبوع
المقبل للمساعده في دفع المحادثات
المتعثره التي يتوسط فيها الاتحاد
الاوروبي
[موسيقى]
علقت الصين اكثر من الف حساب على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي الانتقادها سياسات
الحكومه بشان
وفقا لشبكه بي بي سي البريطانيه
على ما يقرب 13000 انتهاك بما في ذلك
الهجمات على الخبراء والعلماء والعاملين
في المجال الطبي وياتي اكتساحه وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي
الشهر الماضي وسانتشار الفيروس المتزايد
وقبل رفع مطلب الحجر الصحي للزميل
المسافرين الوافدين واعاده فتح الحدود
امام القبباء لاول مره بعد قيود فرضت مده
ثلاث سنوات حيث اعتبرت من الاكثر صرامه في
العالم واثقلت كاهل الاقتصاد الصيني وادت
الى تظاهرات في كل ارجاء البلاد
[موسيقى]
دخلت تونس بصفه رسميه تحت خط الفقره
المائيه بعد سنوات من الجفاف وتراجع
التساقطات المحاصيل الزراعيه باتت مهدده
بعد تخلي الدوله عن سياسه الري بسبب تراجع
مخزون السدود الى الربع تقريبا وهو نبات
يهدد الامن القومي الغذائي للبلاد
[موسيقى]
على مرمى البصري تمتد حقول زراعات الكبرى
في منطقه قلعه الاندلس بمحافظه اريانا
لونها الاخضر بدا يتحول تدريجيا الى
الاصفر بسبب الجفاف وقله الامطار هذه
زراعه مهدده بالانكسار كما يؤكد كمال
ويحيى الفلاحان بالجهه ليجد نفسه عن انقاذ
زراعتهما
لونها كان معناها تواصلت معناها نقص في
الامطار هذه الزراعات هذه الكل توصل
معناها تعطي المنتوج اللي همم
نتاملوا معنا
نتكلم ونعيطوا عليه وزاره الشباب
الوضع هنا لا يختلف وكثيرا عن باقي مناطق
البلاد حيث يواجه اكثر من نصف مليون فلاح
تونسيه خطر ضياع عصابات هذا العام بسبب
الجفاف
الجفاف هو نقص الامطار يهددان الزرعه
والزرعه في تونس التي بات تحت خط الفقر
المائيه وصار فلاحوها في صراع دون اسلحه
مع وضعيه تاريخيه فعالت معها الاصوات
المناديه بضروره اعلان حاله الطوارئ
المناخيه في البلاد
وتاكد السلطات ان الوضع المائيه كارفي حيث
دخل تونس مرحله الفقر المائيه وتتجه
تدريجيا نحو العطش حيث لا تتجاوز سعه
السدود فيها 25% ولا حل الا في الاستغ- عن
ري المحاصيل وترشيد استعمال الماء في باقي
المجالات
مش بتقول كده بس برشا ما عدناش خياره اخرى
انه يلزمني اليوم الراشدوا في المياه
البحر ومحاولته اعاده تاهيل منظومتها
المائيه وسدودها وليد عبد الله العربيه
تونس
في الختام مشاهدينا تذكير بادرس العنويه
المعارك تحت دم على اطراف
تدمير مستودعات اسلحه اوكرانيه في دونياس
تجدد الهتافات ضد خامنئي في ايران والنظام
يواجه المحتاجين في طهران بالرصاص الحي
ايوه
لاول مره منذ ثلاث سنوات التحالف يعود الى
الرقه ومصادر تكشف عن نيته بناء قاعده
عسكريه هناك
الامير
مشاهدينا التاسعه انتهت لكن اخبار العربيه
مستمره والان الى 360 مع الزملاء راويه
وطاهر راويه وطاهر اهلا بكم ببدايه هذه
السنه
العاشره
اسماعيل
الامير هاري